[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
en ce jour qui est à la fois le premier
jour de l'été et un lendemain du premier
tour des élections régionales nous
allons en discuter avec nicolas baverez
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes avocat
essayiste éditorialiste au figaro votre
dernière chronique traite ce matin de la
relation difficile entre les états unis
et la russie
et vous est aussi l'auteur d'un nombre
important d'ouvragés dont le dernier
l'alertent démocratique a été publié aux
édition de l'observatoire bonsoir
alexandre ii avec ce trio d'être
responsable des pages débats du figaro
magazine du figaro vox un bref le ciel
se couche se retrempe ir jamais
exactement et vous est aussi l'auteur de
recomposition le nouveau monde populiste
aux éditions du cerf rires je vous le
disais on va donc consacrer cette
émission à l'analyse de ce premier tour
plein de surprises des élections
régionales
on va pas s'arrêter aux régions
peut-être spécifiquement mais plutôt
essayer d'en tirer quelques danses et
dûment nationaux en commençant par
regardez ce graphique qui donne un peu
les rapports de force
alors il apparaît clairement que les
républicains s'en sortent très bien ils
sont à plus de 28% des voix au niveau
national pour les listes qu'il menait en
revanche pour l'asmo nationale mais
c'est vraiment la contre performance on
l'a beaucoup dit il est en dessous des
20% et pour les autres partis passer
carrément le bas du peloton à la fois
pour les socialistes ou pour en marche
vous avez vu en marche le parti
présidentiel qui a une majorité très
confortable à l'assemblée nationale et
qui fait moins de 11 % des voix et puis
il ya aussi cette contre-performance de
la france insoumise qui en dessous de 6%
n'est pas vraiment en forme alors
peut-être on va se focaliser sur
l'élément le plus spectaculaire la
droite qui semble-t-il s'en sort bien
dans ce premier tour je rappelle
quelques chiffres le score de laurent
wauquiez qui fait 43 8%
le président sortant de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes c'est 12 points de
plus qu'en 2015 et xavier bertrand aussi
qui fait un carton avec 41 4%
le président sortant des autres france
et puis valérie pécresse même si c'est
dans une moindre mesure mais qui a quand
même un très bon score de premier tour
avec 36 % pour la présidente sortante de
la région ile-de-france alors est ce que
la droite est aussi forte que semble le
laisser penser ces chiffres c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué que ça
nous dit jérôme jaffré bien connu des
internautes de point de vue puisque
c'est un invité régulier de l'émission
il était ce matin sur europe 1
alors d'abord c'est un peu un trompe
l'oeil comme les électeurs se soient
énormément abstenus ceux qui sont allés
voter ont un peu porter les sortants les
électeurs ont pratiqué le dégagisme à
l'égard des urnes est très curieusement
se dégage isme profite aux sortants
celle inverse 2017
je regarde que par exemple quand la
droite avait des présidents sortants
elle fait en moyenne 36 % des voix quand
elle n'avait pas de sortant elle ne fait
que 16% des voix
voyez l'énorme différence mais ya
incontestablement c'est très grande
performance de xavier bertrand de
laurent wauquiez à 1 - 2 degrés de
valérie pécresse nicolas baverel à
droite est de retour bon je crois qu'il
faut être très prudent
d'abord c'est un premier tour c'est une
édition régionale et on a quand même
deux tiers d'abstention donc aller tirer
dix grandes des grandes leçons et pourra
jouer d'être modeste je rappelle que
finalement pour les élections
européennes
c'était le rassemblement national qui
était en tête lrm juste derrière on
avait salué la performance des deux
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est plus du
tout le cas
et pour le il ya comme une constante
avec les municipales ou les municipales
on avait une percée des écologistes et
au sein de la gauche qui va pas très
bien les écologistes vont quand même
plutôt deux de bons scores donc devant
le risque social et ce polar
donc en réalité je crois qu'il ya deux
choses qui était dit à l'instant par
jérôme jaffré qui est
qui est le bon sens même c'est que quand
on dit la droite s'en sort bien elle
s'en sort bien d'abord parce qu'elle
était sortante et que dans cette et il y
avait une énorme confusion et la
deuxième chose qui est tout qui doit
quand même être pointé c'est qu'au delà
du sortant il se trouve que en tout cas
dans les cas qui ont été évoqués la
droite avait de bons candidats qui
étaient adossés à de bons bilans et donc
paradoxalement l'entreprise d'emmanuel
macron qui a été de jeter une confusion
complète et sur le le scrutin lui même
sur sa nature et sur les listes
finalement ça s'est retourné et j'allais
dire le les français finalement on prie
l'élection pour ce qu'elles étaient et
ils ont donc voté pour des gens qui
avaient plutôt obtenu de bonnes
performances dans l'eure dans leur
mandat
on verra si c'est confirmé par le
deuxième tour c'est vrai que pour
l'instant on a l'impression que en
dehors de paca où c'est plus disputée
mais on risque d'avoir une reconduction
de tous les président sortant de région
donc si c'était ça montrerait quand même
que la logique c'est de santé un dernier
mot sur la droite quand même c'est que
et d'une certaine manière c'était
étonnant que le party les républicains
dans n'est pas plus profiter c'est qu'au
milieu de toutes ces polémiques de cette
confusion on a une réalité c'est que la
droite aujourd'hui elle est
sociologiquement et idéologiquement
majoritaire ce qui lui manque en réalité
c'est un leader et une stratégie quand
elle a un leader et de stratégie c'était
d'ailleurs intéressant de voir que les
polémiques sur les alliances soient lrm
soit
debout la france soit les alliances
diverses mais toutes ces polémiques
était autour du bloc central de la
droite parce que de fait aujourd'hui le
bloc central du pays
c'est bien le sait bien la droite et
donc on en a eu la traduction dans ce
scrutin
vous sentez un désir de droite avec
centre de vecchio qui serait cohérent
avec ce que j'ai dit que la barre est à
dire que les idées de droite sont
sociologiquement et idéologiquement
majoritaire dans le pays
moi je pense qu'il manquait quelque
chose quand même sur votre graphique
c'est le bleu grand vainqueur de ces
élections c'est le parti des
abstentionnistes et des de la colère 66
% d'abstention donc c'est une victoire
écrasante pour ce parti là je dirais
plus que pour pour la droite la vérité
c'est qu'il ya une sécession de la plèbe
qui a manifesté son mécontentement
envers tous les patriciens et compris
ceux qui se revendiquait antisystème
comme le rassemblement national avec le
risque de conduire vers une dérive jeudi
aux oligarchies qui est une forme de
deux scrutins sont hyper dense est ce
mécontentement là il ya ya ya ce risque
là finalement d'avoir une démocratie à
deux vitesses avec toute une partie de
la population qui finalement considère
que c'est plus son affaire donc moi
c'est surtout ce que vous retient de
deux skoda ensuite je pense qu'il a pas
forcément de de désir de droite il ya
sociologiquement je suis d'accord qu'il
ya certes un enjeu qui peuvent être
qualifiés plutôt de droite qui sont
majoritaires dans le pays sur la
question de la sécurité de l'immigration
voilà du rapport à la mondialisation
mais je suis pas certain que ce soit de
droite ça c'est sûr mais est ce qu'il ya
une envie des républicains je ne suis
pas sûr par contre je te voilà je
tiendrai conséquence malgré tout de ce
scrutin et je pense que la droite est
effectivement bien meilleure position
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était avant ce
que tu as là puisque mécaniquement il va
avoir il va avoir des conséquences je
pense marine le pen devait faire la
démonstration qu'elle pouvait enfin
brisé son plafond de verre qu'elle
pouvait être une candidate crédible pour
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
et bien elle a raté complètement du et
du cou et du coup il pourrait y avoir un
phénomène de vote utile qui se portera
naturellement sur le candidat de droite
donc là il ya une dynamique du
rassemblement national qui à mon avis va
être totalement coupée d'autant plus que
dans la dynamique il ya aussi
l'écartèlement de cette droite entre le
rassemblement national est en marche on
voit qu'elle lui échappe totalement et
ça va être beaucoup plus facile d'être
unis après une victoire qu'après une
série de défaites donc moi je pense que
sarba complètement les cartes pour
l'élection présidentielle même si ça se
jouera on en reparlera sur l'électorat
populaire je vais je vais laisser un peu
parlé nicolas mais il ya des choses un
peu à dire sur qui a gagné pourquoi dans
quelles régions un site intéressant si
on se
on ne peut constater effectivement on ne
peut que constater cette prime aux
sortants dont vous parliez nicolas
baverez mais tous les sortants n'avait
pas la même la même stratégie alors
escaladé stratégie qui était plus
gagnante que d'autres alliés xavier
bertrand qui se revendiquent de droite
même s'il n'est plus chez les
républicains mais qui a toujours été
extrêmement offensif contre le
rassemblement national et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il n'a pas baissé
en intensité hier soir à l'annoncé des
résultats du premier tour regardez ici
nous avons des serré nous avons des
serré pour les briser les mâchoires du
front national leur démagogie leur
proposition stérile leur intolérance
tout ce qui divise et tout ce qu'est le
front national à présent chacun est face
à ses responsabilités
j'ai pris les miennes en faisant du
front national mon seul et unique ennemi
c'est ça qu'il faut faire nicolas pas
vrai pour la droite française n'a
évidemment on se projette un peu en 2022
il faut cogner cogner sur le
rassemblement national
non mais je crois que là en l'occurrence
comme d'ailleurs emmanuel macron xavier
bertrand faisait deux campagnes en une
et donc que cette déclaration qui vient
après un beau succès est destiné à
montrer qu'il est un un meilleur
antidote au rassemblement national que
qu'emmanuel mâcon le le problème des
positionnements tactiques c'est une
chose moi ce qui m'apparaît surtout très
important pour cette élection et qui
manque pour l'instant complètement c'est
que personne n'a élaboré un projet
crédible de redressement du pays
et je pense qu'il ya quand même une
énorme attente ce que montre cette
abstention
il ya effectivement une partie de colère
et des aveux mais il ya aussi une partie
de d'appel de l'électorat et des
électeurs à avoir un débat qui soit
digne de ce nom et pour l'élection
présidentielle ça sera ça sera
extrêmement présent comment la ville
paradoxe c'est qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
sécurité alors que c'est quand même pas
la compétence centrale des des régions
et que par ailleurs il ya eu ensuite
toute une série de jeux tactiques
incompréhensible qu'il était relié qu'à
l'élection présidentielle et ça
visiblement ça a joué deux d'exaspérer
les d'exaspérer les français le jeu si
vous voulez dans votre question il ya
implicitement la poursuite de ce qui a
exaspéré les français dans sa chacra
était sommée de se positionner par
rapport au rassemblement national
problèmes du pays c'est pas de se
positionner par rapport au rassemblement
national c'est de se positionner par
rapport à ce qu'on veut faire pour
sortir d'une situation qui est quand
même maintenant vraiment inquiétante
avec une économie effondré un état
effondré une citoyenneté en berne et une
influence de la france qui est quand
même extrêmement sur le recul en europe
et dans le monde
donc maintenant on l'a bien compris
depuis l'épidémie il suffit de voir tout
ce qui était donc c'est là dessus je
pense que se fera la différence plus que
sur l'or surtout que le rassemblement
national il faut pas limiter évidemment
à des résultats de deere soir mais de
fait il ya beaucoup moins de raisons de
se positionner uniquement face au
rassemblement national depuis hier soir
par ailleurs on peut constater que
laurent wauquiez qui lui de cogner pas
aussi ouvertement canton l'assemblée
nationale a également fait un très bon
score dans sa région auvergne
rhône-alpes à redon et que le rn au
contraire est passé de 25 % à 12 % au
premier tour je vous donne
il ya deux faces dans la stratégie des
années bertrand l'a effectivement au
soir du premier tour il connaît beaucoup
sur le front nord et le rassemblement
national parce qu'il veut se positionner
il se positionne déjà dans le second
tour de la présidentielle en gros il dit
je suis le meilleur adversaire pour
battre marine le pen au second tour il
élimine macron du premier tour mais on a
vu que pendant la campagne
en réalité ceux qui ont cogné contre
leur rassemblement national et sa
laporal aura pas porté bonheur c'est le
gouvernement xavier bertrand barré à lui
à faire il a eu un agent électoral très
efficace qui s'appelait emmanuel
emmanuel macron est en réalité les gens
se sont dit finalement puisque emmanuel
macron veut absolument faire part des
alliés bertrand balas mais le meilleur
moyen de sanctionner emmanuel macron
c'est de voter pour xavier les enfants
qui par ailleurs a fait aussi un travail
sur l'électorat populaire et ça c'est le
soin à mon avis à retenir pour la droite
en tant que président de région qui
était un électorat voilà qui est l
électorat du rassemblement national
c'était le fief de marine le pen et
xavier lacroix a montré qu'en allons
leur parler à la fois sur les questions
régaliennes l'immigration la sécurité et
à la fois sur la question sociale
et bien finalement il s'en sortait pas
si mal donc là il ya il n'y a pas un
projet politique pour la france mais il
ya une orientation
je dirais générale qui pourrait être
l'orientation d'une droite victorieuse à
la présidentielle pardon chers
internautes je vous donne la parole
tardivement alors que vous réagissez car
ce sujet vous passionne à la vraie très
très partagés sur le sens de ce premier
tour et en particulier sur la question
de savoir si les résultats du premier
tour de ces régionales marquent le
retour de la droite vous êtes 51 25 % à
considérer que oui mais vous êtes
nombreux à estimer comme nicole 0,6 et
comme d'ailleurs nous invitait que ce
qui fausse tout c'est l'abstention
une autre nous dit une autre sur
lefigaro.fr c'est son pseudonyme
l'extension des régions en grande région
était une ineptie
la notion de territoire n'existe plus
c'est vrai est ce que pour autant ça
avantage mécaniquement la droite on
pourrait en discuter
je crois que l'abstention au second tour
sera moins importante mais à qui ça
va-t-il profiter nous dit droite en
danger on va voir et puis babineau qui
considère que l'électorat de marine le
pen n'a boudé les urnes et que c'est la
surprise de ce scrutin
merci chers papineau ça nous fait une
transition toute trouvée pour le
deuxième sujet